طيب عبد الملك اليوم هل عقد رونالدو ونادي
النصر
هل عقد رونالدو بالنادي النصر والملكه
العربيه السعوديه للاستفاده من الدون
كسفير لدعم استضافه بطوله 2030 لكاس
العالم سواء في مصر السعوديه واليونان
المبالغ اللي طلعت عنها وكاله الانباء
بخصوص صفحه رونالدو فيها حسب مصدرنا مبالغ
فيها هي اكيد لاعب بقيمه كريستيانو
رونالدو اكيد هتدفع مبلغ كبير جدا جدا بس
الارقام اللي طلعت مبالغ فيها الحاجه
الثانيه حتى الان الاعلان الرسمي
رونالدو للنصر الى 2025
صحيح طيب قال لي لفتني احتفاظه بالرقم
سبعه سي ار 7 برقمه حتى في الدوري السعودي
رونالدو مانشستر يونايتد بدل 17 بعدين رقم
سبعه ريال مدريد يوفنتوس حتى لما رجع
لمانشستر يونايتد برقم 7 حتى في نادي
النصر كان مشاريعوف اللاعب الاوزبكي هو
رقم سبعه نادي النادي النصر لمح قبل فتره
انه رونالدو حجل عندما احول من الرقم سبعه
الى 77
دايما على السيره رقم سبعه بيقول لنا رقم
سبعه هو رقم خير
كرستيانو رونالدو
[موسيقى]
يعني هلا بس عندي سؤال سريع هو راح يقيم
في الرياض بس تقنيه لنفهم وكل عيلته رحتم
على الرياض حتى شفنا جولينا تابعه حساب
نادي النصر عبر تويتر انستغرام
بعد صفقات رونالدو كتب انه الانديه الاخرى
حنعملها من اجل الجلب مستحقات عالميه